The least common PIN number is 8068.
To make them less conspicuous, white horses
in the British army during the First World
War were dyed brown with food colouring.
The world's smallest advert was stencilled
onto a bee's knee.
The caffeine extracted from decaf coffee is
sold to soft-drinks manufacturers.
The first ever webcam was in the computer
lab at Cambridge University.
It was permanently focused on the coffee pot
in the corridor to save the scientists making
pointless trips when it had run out.
There was a law in Sparta against having an
unmanly complexion.
Palm trees are a type of grass.
Before humans reached Hawaii, the dominant
animals there were giant ducks.
Winston Churchill was a druid.
One in eleven people on Earth earn their money
from tourism.
Medieval peasants ate about 4,000 calories
per day, twice as many calories as the average
person eats today.
People are more likely to co-operate with
you if you give them something warm to hold.
A grasshopper becomes more sociable if you
stroke its hind legs.
Wamblecropt is a 17th-century word for 'indigestion'.
The amount of times you need to push down
per minute during CPR is the beat of the song
Staying Alive or Another one Bites the Dust.
Victorian slang for a woman's breasts was
'Cupid's kettledrums'.